I really enjoy to a war war hammer these
are two franchises that I've wanted to
to meet for years and they both have
unique aspects that kind of they were
they were meant to be together you've
got the grand battles of fantasy of
Warhammer and also the large campaigns
giant maps and massive amounts of
infantry from total war and they both
work together wonderfully in a way that
I've been hoping for since I've been
about 14 total war war hammer was pretty
cool I struggled with some areas there
was less of a tutorial than in earlier
total war game so there was quite a bit
of assumed knowledge at least in the
state that is currently in right now I
know they're still working on some
things which is contributed to the delay
things like balancing but I found early
on it was easy to forget that you had a
settlement way back where that needed to
be defended each race plays very
differently the humans are kind of like
your most classical total war factions
with the addition of magic and Griffin's
whereas dwarves are very defensive and
focus on artillery and even have a book
of grudges where they take note of any
time you've stepped against them and
then there's things like green skins you
have to constantly fight about the
entire campaign or they just evolved
into bickering and killing themselves I
think the fantasy definitely added to
the experience not that I didn't like
the total war settings where it was just
like a bunch of dudes who were in
different forms of military but this
just felt very like a movie esque it
felt really cool if I like you're in the
middle of a big fantasy warfare setting
and I don't think I can think of any
other games that really give you that
large-scale real-time combat feel with
fantasy creatures one of the most
interesting additions to total war
warhammer our story based battles and he
requests so sometimes battles will pop
up in the campaign map that have kind of
a scenario attached to them so you can
march your army whatever it consists of
to that point and take place in a little
bow that will give you a bonus and we'll
have a little bit of lore attached to it
whereas he requests are how you develop
your legendary Lords so in the case of
the vampire counts manfred von Kahr
stein he will have a set of quests and
if you accomplish said quest whether
it's to take a town or sacks
we're or killer warboss you will unlock
new mounts new weapons new war gear and
each piece of war gear gives a bonus
whether it's a legendary aura or attack
spells anything like that and that is
new to warhammer total war especially in
the way it gives you new items and you
know eventually a flying dragon one of
the things I found to be a little
challenging was the vampire faction that
we were playing as most of the time it
doesn't have any ranged units and that's
not something that any total war games
have had before with any of their
factions and it is extremely challenging
going up against especially the humans
who have so many ranged units one of the
skirmish battles that we got to play
which was removed from the campaign was
us being the humans against a bunch of
vampires and it was pretty easy to wipe
them out with ranged units so being on
the other side of that was really tricky
and I think it's going to just take
experience with the faction and figuring
out where the advantages are against the
other sides and that's something the
total war developers are working with to
try and rebalance and I'm sure we'll
have to work with to figure out so it
should get better one thing as a little
bit disappointed in as someone who came
from a background of painting the
Warhammer figures and collecting them I
always went off color scheme when I was
painting my little figures and total war
warhammer isn't really giving you much
in a way of customization when it comes
to your entire army i form was thinking
that I would create a green-skinned army
and dress all my orks in pink vests and
send one into battle but unfortunately
at the moment we can't quite make the
pink orcs this does feel really similar
to other total war games I think what
makes it different is if you really pay
attention to the battle and you just
look at your creatures and you're like a
massive swarms of bats as I said or your
heroes are actually huge werewolves and
things like that that is so different
it's like a completely familiar total
war format with this other injection of
a really cool fantasy theme that I thing
works quite well from what I've seen so
far I think the Warhammer franchise in
the Warhammer law adds a lot to total
war previously took war felt like you
were kind of creating your own game and
your own story now with the addition of
years of law from the Warhammer
franchise we're getting to know
characters we're getting to know
world beyond what we can just see on a
map it's not just a historical version
of our wide world so that already adds a
lot to the world a total war and then
like I said you have things like goblins
orcs dragons vampire bats as well as a
slew of magic so really total war has
been begging to the fantasy element to
be injected into it for years and I have
to say it's pretty exciting and what
they have made with these two giant
franchises finally meeting is pretty
great so far
you